A quick warning-- there are curse words that are unbeeped in today's episode of the show. If you prefer a beeped version, you can find that at our website, ThisAmericanLife.org.
温馨提示：今天的节目中会出现未消音的粗口。如果您更倾向于收听消音版本，请前往我们的网站 ThisAmericanLife.org。
Remember that old-fashioned idea that two people who disagree about politics could sit down, talk. Each would see the other's point of view. LBJ used to quote scripture as he headed into political negotiations-- "Come, let us reason together." Now, of course, we all realize that that's impossible. I'm overstating for effect, but you know what I mean, right?
还记得那种老派的想法吗？即两个政见不合的人可以坐下来谈谈。双方都能理解对方的观点。林登·约翰逊总统在进行政治谈判前常引用经文说：“来吧，让我们一起理性探讨。”当然，现在我们都意识到那是不可能的了。我这么说有点夸大其词，但你明白我的意思，对吧？
There was this famous moment a few years ago when all this seemed way more possible, a moment which was so long ago now. It came about because of this thing that happened at a presidential press conference.
几年前有一个著名的时刻，那时这一切似乎还很有可能，但现在回想起来已经是太久之前的事了。那是因为总统新闻发布会上发生的一件事。
Before I take your questions, I want to talk for a few minutes about the progress we're making on health insurance reform.
在回答你们的问题之前，我想花几分钟谈谈我们在医保改革方面取得的进展。
That, of course, is Barack Obama. The year is 2009. One of my co-workers here at the radio show, Robyn Semien, has been revisiting this piece of very recent history. Because it is so recent, but feels like it's almost quaint, the fact that people thought that sitting down and talking together might work.
当然，那是巴拉克·奥巴马。时间是2009年。我们广播节目的同事罗宾·塞米恩一直在回顾这段非常近期的历史。之所以说它近期，但又感觉几乎有些古老，是因为人们曾认为坐下来谈谈或许真的有用。
Hey, Robyn.
嘿，罗宾。
Hey, Ira. OK, so I talked to Dan Pfeiffer. He's the deputy communications guy in the Obama White House at the time. He was there in the room for that press conference. So beforehand, they'd gone over with the president the 10 specific reporters they wanted him to call on.
嘿，艾拉。好吧，我采访了丹·法伊弗。他是当时奥巴马白宫的副通讯联络官。他当时就在那场新闻发布会的现场。所以事前，他们和总统一起过了一遍那10位他们希望总统点名提问的特定记者。
And he got to the end of that list. And instead of going off stage-- and you can tell the president was feeling very good about his performance, because it's usually when he thinks he's doing well that he will take more questions. And nothing good ever comes of the "one more question."
他念完了名单。但他没有离开舞台——你可以看出总统对自己的表现非常满意，因为通常当他觉得自己表现出色时，他就会多回答几个问题。而“再问一个问题”通常都不会带来什么好结果。
All right. I tried to make that short so that Lynn Sweet would get her last question in.
好的。我尽量说短一点，好让琳恩·斯威特能问出她最后一个问题。
Thank you, Mr. President.
谢谢你，总统先生。
And I remember this question like it was yesterday.
我记得这个问题，就像昨天发生的一样。
Recently, Professor Henry Louis Gates Jr. was arrested at his home in Cambridge. What does that incident say to you, and what does it say about race relations in America?
最近，亨利·路易斯·盖茨教授在剑桥的家中被捕。这件事对你有什么启示？它反映了美国怎样的种族关系？
Well, I should say at the outset that Skip Gates is a friend, so I may be a little biased here. I don't know all the facts.
嗯，首先我得说，斯基普·盖茨是我的朋友，所以我可能有点偏袒。我不了解所有事实。
OK, so just to remind everybody, Henry Louis Gates Jr., a famous Harvard professor, African-American scholar, he comes home one night. He's trying to get into his own house. He has a problem getting in. Like, the keys don't work or something. And someone sees him and calls the police.
好了，提醒一下大家，亨利·路易斯·盖茨是一位著名的哈佛教授、非裔美国学者，他一天晚上回到家。他进家门时遇到了麻烦。比如，钥匙打不开门之类的。有人看见了就报了警。
The cops show up, and the responding officer, Sergeant James Crowley, he learns that it is, in fact, Gates' own house. But then they get into an argument, and it escalates, and they both have words, and then Gates gets arrested.
警察赶到现场，出警的警官詹姆斯·克劳利中士得知这确实是盖茨自己的家。但随后他们发生了争执，事态升级，两人都说了些重话，然后盖茨就被捕了。
Right. So this comes up at the press conference.
没错。所以这件事在新闻发布会上被提了出来。
Yeah, and President Obama is so comfortable in his skin. He is so casual in this moment that he even makes this little joke that it is impossible to imagine him making now.
是的，奥巴马总统当时表现得非常从容。那一刻他是如此随意，甚至开了个小玩笑，让人无法想象他现在还会那样做。
Right, I mean, if I was trying to jigger into-- well, I guess this is my house now, so--
没错，我是说，如果我试图撬门进——好吧，我想这现在是我的家了，所以——
[PRESS CORPS LAUGHING]
[记者团笑声]
It probably wouldn't happen. But let's say my old house in Chicago-- here, I'd get shot.
那可能不会发生。但假设是在我芝加哥的老家——在这里，我会被枪击。
OK, but then he says this. This is the part that's going to cause all the trouble.
好吧，但他接着说了这句话。这就是那句会惹出所有麻烦的话。
I think it's fair to say, number one, any of us would be pretty angry. Number two, that the Cambridge police acted stupidly in arresting somebody when there was already proof that they were in their own home. And number three, what I think we know, separate and apart from this incident, is that there is a long history in this country of African-Americans and Latinos being stopped by law enforcement disproportionately. And that's just a fact.
我认为公平地说，第一，我们任何一个人都会感到非常愤怒。第二，剑桥警方在已经证明当事人就在自己家中时进行逮捕，这种做法是愚蠢的。第三，我认为我们所知道的，撇开这起事件不谈，是这个国家存在着长期以来非裔美国人和拉丁裔被执法部门不成比例地拦截的历史。这只是一个事实。
So the night ends, and you're thinking that was pretty good?
所以那天晚上结束时，你觉得表现得还不错？
Yeah, I felt fine. Yeah, we survived, which is the goal of any press conference.
是的，我感觉还可以。是的，我们挺过来了，这是任何新闻发布会的目标。
Usually, we'd do a press conference, I would walk back with him and sort of like do post-game analysis. But in this case, I think he might have gone upstairs to bed. Because I'm pretty sure we were in the East Wing, in the State Dining Room. So I don't remember talking to him about it that night. He might have talked to Valerie right afterwards.
通常我们会开完发布会，我会和他一起走回去，做点赛后分析之类的。但在这种情况下，我想他可能直接上楼睡觉了。因为我很确定我们当时是在东翼的国宴厅。所以我不太记得那天晚上和他谈论过这件事。他可能紧接着就和瓦莱丽谈过了。
Valerie Jarrett, one of Obama's senior advisors, she was at the press conference too.
瓦莱丽·贾勒特，奥巴马的高级顾问之一，她当时也参加了新闻发布会。
And I remember listening to the answer and thinking, yeah, that sounds right. And then when he said the word, stupidly, I paused for a minute. And then I thought about it, and I said, all right, well, when somebody gets arrested in their own home, that is pretty odd, right? And I didn't give much more thought to it.
我记得听到这个回答时想，是的，听起来是对的。然后当他说到“愚蠢地”这个词时，我停顿了一会儿。接着我思考了一下，我说，好吧，当某人在自己家里被捕时，这确实很奇怪，对吧？我没有再多想。
But by the time I got from the East Room in the residence back to my office in the West Wing, it had blown up.
但当我从住所的东厅回到西翼的办公室时，事情已经炸开锅了。
Oh, that night?
哦，那天晚上？
I mean, literally within six or seven minutes. It just went viral right away. It was a big deal. Almost instantly, the reaction to him saying the word "stupidly" just was an instant problem.
我是说，确实是在六七分钟之内。它立刻就在网上疯传了。这成了一件大事。几乎瞬间，对他使用“愚蠢地”这个词的反应就成了一个即时的问题。
After accusing police of acting stupidly for arresting a Harvard professor in his own home, President Obama came under fire.
在指责警方逮捕了一位在自己家中的哈佛教授是愚蠢行为后，奥巴马总统受到了抨击。
Cambridge police are not stupid. I think everybody that knows us knows that. I think the president should make an apology to all law enforcement personnel throughout the entire country who took offense to this.
剑桥警察并不愚蠢。我想认识我们的人都知道这一点。我认为总统应该向全国所有感到被冒犯的执法人员道歉。
This president, I think, has exposed himself as a guy, over and over and over again, who has a deep-seated hatred for white people or the white culture. I don't know what it is. I'm not saying that he doesn't like white people, I'm saying he has a problem. He has a-- this guy is, I believe, a racist.
我认为这位总统一次又一次地暴露了他是一个对白人或白人文化有着根深蒂固仇恨的人。我不知道是什么原因。我并不是说他不喜欢白人，我是说他有问题。他——我相信这个人是个种族主义者。
That was Glenn Beck on Fox News.
那是福克斯新闻台的格伦·贝克。
Kind of famously.
相当有名的一段言论。
Yeah. So that was one reaction. But simultaneously, civil rights groups are calling the White House and thanking Obama for putting a spotlight on this issue that was important to them. So essentially, President Obama had effortlessly divided the country with his one word, "stupidly."
是的。这就是一种反应。但与此同时，民权组织正在致电白宫，感谢奥巴马关注了对他们来说很重要的问题。所以本质上，奥巴马总统用他那一个词“愚蠢地”，毫不费力地分裂了这个国家。
It was not intended to trigger-- polarize the police from the communities that they serve and protect. It was really kind of an offhanded comment. And if, perhaps, he hadn't said "stupidly," things would not have gotten as derailed as they did. If he had said, for example, "It's understandable that Skip would be annoyed that a police officer would arrest him in his home," I think people would have said, yeah, I'd be annoyed. But when he said something about the police officer's intent or behavior, I think that's what got under people's skin.
他本意并非要煽动——让警察与他们服务和保护的社区对立。那真的只是一种随口的评论。如果他当时没有说“愚蠢地”，事情或许就不会变得如此失控。比方说，如果他说“斯基普因为被警官在自己家中逮捕而感到恼火是可以理解的”，我认为人们会说，是的，换我也会恼火。但当他评价警官的动机或行为时，我认为这才是触怒人们的地方。
So inside the White House, they go into full crisis mode. They're hoping it'll die down, but it doesn't. So they come up with this idea to invite Gates and Crowley to the White House to sit down and have a beer.
所以白宫内部进入了全面危机模式。他们希望这件事能平息下来，但并没有。于是他们想出了这个主意：邀请盖茨和克劳利到白宫坐下来喝杯啤酒。
And then that led the press to become very interested in what I believe they deemed the Beer Summit. And there were demands for them to cover the Beer Summit, as if it would be some violation of norms and transparency if they did not get a chance to take a picture of the Beer Summit.
然后这引起了媒体的极大兴趣，他们称之为“啤酒峰会”。还有人要求报道这场啤酒峰会，仿佛如果没能拍到啤酒峰会的照片，就是对规范和透明度的某种违背。
Right.
没错。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
And yeah, we didn't want to make it a thing.
是的，我们不想把这搞得太正式。
Those are nice pictures of the garden.
那些花园的照片很漂亮。
So they get together for beers to calm the nation down. People take pictures. And as we all know, that did not work.
于是他们聚在一起喝啤酒，试图让国家平静下来。人们拍照。但正如我们所知，那并没有奏效。
Yeah, no, it still comes up. Like a month ago, as you know, our colleague, Zoe Chace, was at a Trump rally in New Hampshire to talk to people there about why the country is so divided. And two separate people brought this up on their own, pointed to this as the moment that they knew that Obama was out to divide the country.
是的，不，这话题依然会被提起。就像一个月前，如你所知，我们的同事佐伊·蔡斯在新罕布什尔州的特朗普集会上采访人们，询问为什么国家如此分裂。有两个人主动提到了这件事，指出这就是他们断定奥巴马意在分裂国家的时刻。
What he did, his first-- what, within his first year, he went after the cops in Cambridge.
他所做的，他的第一——什么，在他执政的第一年，他就对剑桥的警察下手了。
That's the thing that started it.
那是这一切的开端。
I think that's when it really started. He started it. Just the things that he did, starting with the Beer Summit we had in Cambridge. You know, all these dumb things that he did, you know? It was his agenda.
我认为那是真正开始的时候。是他挑起的。就他做的那些事，从我们在剑桥举办的啤酒峰会开始。你知道，所有那些他做的蠢事，你知道吗？这是他的议程。
OK, so Beer Summit did not unify America.
好吧，所以啤酒峰会并没有统一美国。
Right. I have thought about this so much since it happened, just the casual way that President Obama stepped into this. I've wondered if he was like, I set the table already with the race conversation as a candidate, so people know where I'm coming from. I wondered if maybe he was just trying to test the waters right then. Maybe he just thought, well, let's just see how-- let's just see where we are.
没错。自从那件事发生以来，我思考了无数次，仅仅是奥巴马总统漫不经心地介入这件事的方式。我曾想过，他是否觉得：我作为候选人已经为种族议题铺好了路，所以人们知道我的立场。我曾想过，也许他当时只是想试探一下。也许他只是想，好吧，我们看看情况——看看我们现在的处境。
I don't know that there was that much thought. I think, to your point-- and honestly, Robyn, I haven't thought about this before you put it to me. But I'm sure, because the race speech had gone so well, and was embraced broadly, and was so raw and honest about himself, he hoped that people had a better sense of who he was. And because he had won the presidency and had comported himself throughout his short tenure at that point as a president for all of America, I think perhaps he thought he had the standing to say that and not experience the backlash.
我不知道当时有没有想那么多。我想，针对你的观点——老实说，罗宾，在你提出之前我没考虑过。但我敢肯定，因为那次种族演讲进行得非常顺利，被广泛接受，而且非常真实诚恳，他希望人们对他有更好的了解。而且因为他赢得了总统职位，并且在那时一直表现得像一位全美总统，我想也许他认为自己有立场说那番话，而不会遭受反弹。
And so that was a teaching moment, too, that, you know--
所以那也是一个教学时刻，你知道——
For him.
对他而言。
For him. For all of us, yeah.
对他而言。对我们所有人，是的。
Dan told me he thinks that it wasn't what Obama said, but that he was the first black president in the White House. And that if it wasn't this, it would have been something else.
丹告诉我，他认为问题的关键不在于奥巴马说了什么，而在于他是白宫的第一位黑人总统。如果不是因为这件事，也会因为别的事。
OK, but if the goal of the Beer Summit was just three people sitting around trying to understand each other a little bit better, like, even for those people did it work?
好吧，但如果啤酒峰会的目标只是三个人坐在一起试图更好地了解对方，那么即使对当事人来说，这真的起作用了吗？
I mean, yeah, it kind of did. Like, they were really mad before. And then after the Beer Summit, Sergeant Crowley did this press conference where he says, you know, we agree that we both have a lot to learn from each other, and we want to stay in touch.
我是说，是的，某种程度上确实起作用了。比如，他们之前真的很生气。然后啤酒峰会之后，克劳利中士开了个新闻发布会，他说，你知道，我们一致认为我们都有很多东西要向对方学习，我们想保持联系。
And they stay in touch?
他们保持联系了吗？
Yeah, it seems like it. Since then, Gates has said that he and Sergeant Crowley have developed a really good relationship. And then he did this thing-- you know, he has this PBS TV show where he tests celebrities' DNA and tells them about their history. So he asked Crowley to do a DNA test, and found out that they have a common Irish ancestor, a cousin.
是的，看起来是这样。从那以后，盖茨说他和克劳利中士建立了一种很好的关系。然后他做了这件事——你知道，他有个公共电视节目，他会测试名人的基因并告诉他们关于自己的历史。所以他请克劳利做了基因测试，发现他们有一个共同的爱尔兰祖先，是表亲。
So Robyn, in other words, it is possible for people to get along and become friends, and see each other's points of view, especially around the magic potion that we call beer. But we live in a country where most of the nation, for one reason or another, chooses not to believe that.
所以罗宾，换句话说，人们是有可能和睦相处并成为朋友，理解对方观点的，尤其是在我们称之为啤酒的这种神奇药水的帮助下。但我们生活在一个国家，大多数国民因为某种原因，选择不相信这一点。
It seems that way, yeah.
看起来确实如此。
Well, that is actually our show today, people sitting down trying to see the other person's point of view over beer. In all these stories-- no kidding-- beer is involved at a critical turning point. In one story, the fate of an entire nation is at stake. Actually, now that I think of it, it's true for the other story, too. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
好吧，这就是我们今天的节目，人们坐下来试图通过啤酒去理解对方的观点。在所有这些故事中——不骗你——啤酒都出现在了关键的转折点。在一个故事里，整个国家的命运危在旦夕。事实上，现在想想，另一个故事也是如此。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这个美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act One, "One for My Baby, and One More for the Road." So with everybody in the United States and Europe breaking off into political groups who seem to understand each other less and less these days, this German journalist named Bastian Berbner spent the last three years reporting on people from these kinds of groups that dislike and mistrust each other, and see things very differently, who actually sit down and try to get along. He's traveled to a bunch of different countries looking for examples of this, where people do indeed somehow come to see eye to eye. So for example, in Denmark, he interviewed policemen who decided that the very best way to combat the most radical people they faced-- jihadists and neo-Nazis-- was to invite them in for coffee, with, I have to say, amazing results.
第一幕，“一杯给我，再来一杯带走”。随着美国和欧洲的每个人都分裂成似乎越来越难以互相理解的政治派别，这位名叫巴斯蒂安·伯布纳的德国记者花了三年时间报道这些彼此厌恶和不信任、对事物看法大相径庭的群体中的人们，是如何坐下来并尝试和睦相处的。他前往许多不同的国家寻找这样的例子，即人们确实在某种程度上做到了求同存异。例如，在丹麦，他采访了警察，他们决定对抗所面临的最激进群体——圣战分子和新纳粹分子——最好的方式是邀请他们喝咖啡，不得不说，效果惊人。
And the most extreme example of this that he found was in Botswana, where for decades now, the government has been running this kind of big social experiment to fight tribalism. Basically what happens is that, every year, the government tells thousands of civil servants to just pack up their belongings and move, sometimes very far from home, to live and work with people who are sometimes very different from them. This plan is not popular. Sometimes a parent is forced to work hundreds of miles from their own family. But the government has stubbornly stuck with this policy for decades.
而他发现的最极端的例子是在博茨瓦纳，几十年来，政府一直在进行这种大型社会实验来对抗部落主义。基本上，政府每年都会告诉成千上万的公务员收拾行李搬迁，有时离家很远，去与那些有时与他们截然不同的人生活和工作。这个计划并不受欢迎。有时父母被迫在离家人数百英里的地方工作。但政府几十年来一直顽固地坚持这项政策。
Here's Bastian.
这就是巴斯蒂安的讲述。
When Botswana became independent from Britain in 1966, it was one of the last African countries to do so. Imagine, the colonialists leave and you are the first president of Botswana. For years, all around you, you have seen the same story over and over again-- countries become independent, ethnic violence follows.
当博茨瓦纳在1966年从英国独立时，它是最后几个这样做的非洲国家之一。想象一下，殖民者离开了，你是博茨瓦纳的第一任总统。多年来，在你身边，你一遍又一遍地看到同样的故事——国家独立，随之而来的是民族暴力。
Mali became independent in 1960. Two years later, the Tuaregs started a civil war. Congo, same story. Soon after its independence, the province of Katanga tried to break away. Nigeria-- independence in 1960, very soon the Igbos and Hausa started clashing.
马里在1960年独立。两年后，图阿雷格人发动了内战。刚果，同样的故事。独立后不久，加丹加省就试图分裂。尼日利亚——1960年独立，很快伊博人和豪萨人就开始冲突。
Having seen all of that, the early leaders in Botswana knew they had a problem. Because the exact thing that had fueled the violence in all those countries, they had it as well.
目睹了这一切，博茨瓦纳的早期领导人知道他们面临一个问题。因为所有那些国家暴力背后的根源，他们同样也有。
If you think about that these borders were just drawn up. And some of them really straight borders. They could have cut through a person, literally, you know.
如果你想到这些边界只是被随意画出来的。其中一些边界画得非常直。它们甚至可能直接从一个人身上划过，你知道。
This is Unity Dow, the foreign minister of Botswana. She was a kid back in the '60s, when a few people in London drew the borders of her country on a map, creating Botswana. And like in all those other places in Africa, they were putting a bunch of ethnic groups together that didn't really like each other-- the Kalanga in the north, the Bakwena south of the Kalahari Desert, the Bangwato in the center.
这是博茨瓦纳的外交部长尤妮蒂·多。她在60年代还是个孩子，当时伦敦的几个人在地图上画了她国家的边界，创建了博茨瓦纳。和非洲其他所有地方一样，他们把一群并不是很喜欢对方的族群强行放在一起——北部的卡兰加人，卡拉哈里沙漠南部的巴奎纳人，中部的邦瓦托人。
In Botswana, everyone refers to these groups as tribes. So that's what I'm going to say in this story. In Botswana, there were 20 tribes, give or take. They spoke different languages, had different traditions, and now they were forced into one country. So the early leaders figured, to avoid that kind of violence here, what we need to do is break up the tribal identities and form a true nation. No more us, no more them, just a we. But how do you do that?
在博茨瓦纳，每个人都把这些群体称为部落。所以我在这个故事里也会这么说。在博茨瓦纳，大约有20个部落。他们说不同的语言，有不同的传统，而现在他们被强行合并为一个国家。所以早期领导人想，为了避免这里的暴力，我们需要做的是打破部落认同，形成一个真正的国家。不再是“我们”和“他们”，而只是一个“我们”。但你该怎么做呢？
They came up with a plan. First, they decided, everyone needs to understand each other. So in schools, they would only teach English and Setswana-- the other tribe languages, not at all.
他们想出了一个计划。首先，他们决定，每个人都需要互相理解。所以在学校，他们只教英语和茨瓦纳语——完全不教其他部落的语言。
Second, to keep people from fighting over land, they gave a piece of land to anyone who wished. And they said everything underneath that land belongs to the state. This is important, because this is one of the diamond-richest countries on Earth.
其次，为了防止人们争夺土地，他们给任何想要土地的人一块土地。他们说土地之下的一切都属于国家。这很重要，因为这是地球上最富有的钻石产出国之一。
So what happens if I'm given a piece of land, I settle there, I dig, and I find a rich diamond mine.
那么，如果我被分到一块地，我在那里定居，挖掘，然后发现了一个富有的钻石矿，会发生什么？
Well, you get moved.
嗯，你会被搬走。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
That you get moved. You have to declare that diamond, you must surrender it. It's against the law to actually keep it for yourself. You can't just find a diamond and say, oh, I found it. Once you find it, it is not yours. There is a law that just very clearly says it's not yours. It belongs to everybody. So you would just get another piece of land someplace else.
你会被搬走。你必须申报那颗钻石，你必须上交它。自己私藏它是违法的。你不能仅仅发现一颗钻石就说，哦，我发现了它。一旦你发现它，它就不属于你。有一条法律非常明确地规定它不属于你。它属于每个人。所以你只会换到别处得到另一块土地。
I would be so frustrated.
我会非常沮丧。
Well, I'm sorry for your troubles.
嗯，很抱歉让你遇到这种麻烦。
[BOTH CHUCKLING]
[两人笑声]
There was one more thing, probably the most important one, people told me-- the transfers. Remember, each tribe had its territory. So if you were from a certain village in the north, you were most likely Kalanga. If you were from the Central District, probably Bangwato. So they figured, why not make all civil servants move to a different tribal area from their own for a few years? That would make sure that there are teachers and doctors everywhere in the country. But also, it would force people to mix. It would be an anti-tribalism tool.
还有一件事，可能也是人们告诉我最重要的一件——调动制度。记住，每个部落都有自己的领地。所以如果你来自北部的某个村庄，你很可能是卡兰加人。如果你来自中部地区，可能是邦瓦托人。所以他们想，为什么不强制所有公务员在几年内调动到不同于自己所属的部落区域呢？这能确保全国各地都有老师和医生。但它也会强迫人们融合。这是一种反部落主义的工具。
When you move people around, you are indirectly forcing them to take that culture in that new home, to adopt the new culture, and even to call that home. You're forcing alliances, and you are forcing friendships.
当你四处调动人们时，你是在间接地强迫他们接纳那个新家园的文化，去采纳新的文化，甚至把那里称为家。你在强迫建立联盟，你在强迫建立友谊。
Can you force friendships? Does that kind of thing work? The transfers affected everyone working for the government, by far the largest employer in the country-- engineers, administrators, doctors, nurses, and most of all, teachers.
你能强迫建立友谊吗？这种事行得通吗？这种调动影响了所有为政府工作的人，这是该国最大的雇主——工程师、行政人员、医生、护士，尤其是老师。
When I was in Botswana, I talked to 20 teachers to find out if this works, and what it's like for the people going through it. I'm going to tell you the story of one of the teachers, a woman named Carol Ramolotsana. In a way, Carol's story is typical of what I found, but she also stood out to me. I'll tell you why in a minute.
我在博茨瓦纳时，采访了20位老师，想看看这是否有效，以及对经历它的人来说是什么感觉。我要讲讲其中一位老师的故事，一个叫卡罗尔·拉莫洛萨纳的女人。在某种程度上，卡罗尔的故事是我发现的典型，但她也让我印象深刻。稍后我会告诉你原因。
So the teachers would always ask you, what do you want to be when you grow up? I said, I want to be a teacher like you, ma'am.
老师们总是会问你，你长大后想做什么？我说，我想像你一样当老师，女士。
Carol told me she became a teacher for the reasons a lot of people do-- she liked the one she had as a kid.
卡罗尔告诉我，她成为老师的原因和很多人一样——她喜欢她小时候的那位老师。
This lady was a lady who always, every morning when she gets to school, she will look at us. She wouldn't shout at us. If you didn't comb your hair, she will say, baby, come here. She will comb your hair nicely. She would ask us, did you have breakfast? She was this kind of a lady who always come with foods to make.
那位女士每天早上到学校时，都会看着我们。她不会对我们大吼大叫。如果你没梳好头发，她会说，宝贝，过来。她会帮你把头发梳得很好。她会问我们，你吃早餐了吗？她是那种总是带着食物来的老师。
What did she bring?
她带来了什么？
Most of the time, she brought oranges. And she would just sit there, cut the oranges, and just give to us. And she said, you know, I love you so much. And we said, we love you, teacher.
大多数时候，她带的是橙子。她会坐在那里，切开橙子，然后分给我们。她说，你知道，我非常爱你们。我们说，我们爱你，老师。
In 2004, Carol was working in a school in the capital city, Gaborone. She was 28, and everything was going great. She loved teaching. All her friends were in the city. At night, they went out to eat in Chinese restaurants. They went dancing. They were happy.
2004年，卡罗尔在首都哈博罗内的学校教书。她28岁，一切都很顺利。她热爱教学。她所有的朋友都在城里。晚上，他们会去中国餐馆吃饭。他们去跳舞。他们很开心。
But then one day, the head of the school where she taught called her in and handed her a letter. She was being transferred.
但有一天，她任教学校的校长叫她进去，给了她一封信。她要被调走了。
With immediate effect. I still have the letter now-- you are transferred with immediate effect.
立即生效。那封信我现在还留着——你被立即调走。
The head of the school told her the name of the place she was going, Lentsweletau, "Lion's Hill."
校长告诉了她她要去的地方的名字，伦茨韦莱陶，“狮子山”。
Oh, God. I didn't even know the place. I asked him, where is that place? He told me, it's a village, it's a small village. And I just saw from his eyes and his looks that he was just consoling me.
噢，天哪。我甚至不知道那个地方。我问他，那是哪里？他告诉我，那是一个村庄，一个小村庄。我从他的眼神和神情中看出他只是在安慰我。
Oh, so he knew the place.
哦，所以他知道那个地方。
He knew the place, and he knew the place wasn't that good.
他知道那个地方，而且他知道那地方不太好。
Carol had known about the transfers of course, but she had always figured maybe she would get lucky. Well, she didn't. She had just paid for some accounting classes. If she went to this village, she wasn't going to get her money back. She feared that she would lose everything that was important to her-- her friends, her clubs, her restaurants. And she liked being among people like herself, people she had things in common with.
卡罗尔当然知道调动制度，但她一直以为也许自己会幸运一点。好吧，她没有。她刚刚付了会计课程的学费。如果她去了那个村庄，她的钱就拿不回来了。她害怕失去所有对她重要的东西——她的朋友、她的俱乐部、她的餐馆。而且她喜欢和像自己一样的人在一起，那些与她有共同点的人。
And there was nothing that I can do.
但我什么也做不了。
Did you try?
你尝试过吗？
I tried. I tried. I spent about a month-- tried moving from one office to another, just to no avail.
我试过。我试过。我花了一个月左右的时间——试图在不同的办公室之间奔走，但无济于事。
She'd walk into the Ministry of Education with her letter, saying, please, can't you put me somewhere closer? Or at least delay so I can finish my classes? She wasn't getting anywhere. Most people don't.
她拿着信走进教育部，恳求道，求求你，不能把我调到离家近点的地方吗？或者至少推迟一下让我上完课？她到处碰壁。大多数人都是这样。
That woman, Unity Dow, before she became foreign minister, she was the Minister of Education, and she had to deal with people like Carol all the time. She taught me that once a teacher brought in her elderly mother, pleading, please don't transfer me, I have to take care of her. Unity said that woman could barely walk, and it was clear the woman wouldn't live much longer. Still, she said, sorry, lots of people your age have an elderly parent, I can't do anything for you.
那位尤妮蒂·多女士，在成为外交部长之前，她是教育部长，她总是要应付像卡罗尔这样的人。她告诉我，有一次一位老师带着她年迈的母亲来，恳求说，求求你不要调走我，我必须照顾她。尤妮蒂说那位妇女几乎无法行走，很明显她活不了多久了。尽管如此，她说，抱歉，很多你这个年纪的人都有年迈的父母，我帮不了你。
Carol couldn't get out of it either. She was desperate.
卡罗尔也没能逃掉。她当时很绝望。
I was telling my mother, you know, mama, I want to come back home, you know. That is what is happening. You know, I don't think I can go on, you know, being a teacher. But my mother, on the other hand, would say, no, my daughter. Just go. Just go. You will see how it goes. Just go.
我告诉妈妈，你知道，妈妈，我想回家。就是这样。你知道，我不认为我还能继续，你知道，当老师。但另一方面，我妈妈会说，不，我的女儿。去吧。去吧。你会看到情况会变好的。去吧。
Carol knew nothing about the place where she was headed.
卡罗尔对自己要去的地方一无所知。
I really didn't know them. You know, the fact that you are speaking different languages. And I wasn't even interested-- really, I wasn't even interested in knowing them that much. To me, I just felt like they are just people that I don't have to bother knowing them.
我真的不知道他们。你知道，事实上你们说的是不同的语言。我甚至不感兴趣——真的，我甚至没兴趣去了解他们。对我来说，我觉得他们只是我不必费心了解的人。
Carol's tribe was kind of the elite. The founder of the state, for example, he was from her tribe. And it was his grandfather who, back in the 1800s, went to London to negotiate with Queen Victoria. The place where she was going, very different story. She says they used to be enslaved by another tribe.
卡罗尔的部落算是精英阶层。比如，国家的创始人就来自她的部落。正是他的祖父在1800年代前往伦敦与维多利亚女王谈判。而她要去的地方，故事大不相同。她说他们过去曾被另一个部落奴役。
One day, the ministry sent a truck to take Carol's things to the new place. She didn't go with it. She stayed for two more weeks. And then, reluctantly, she got in her car, drove out of the city. And when she approached a village--
有一天，政府派了一辆卡车把卡罗尔的东西运到新地方。她没有随车一起去。她又待了两周。然后，不情愿地，她上了车，开车出了城。当她接近那个村庄时——
There was a building, an old building. You know, I was like, oh God, what is this? On the other side of the road, there was something like-- maybe they wanted to build a filling station, but they didn't go along with the structure, but they just left the things there. There was the tank that showed that this place was supposed to be a filling station.
有一座建筑，一座古老的建筑。你知道，我就想，噢天哪，这是什么？马路的另一边，有一些像——也许他们想建个加油站，但没有继续建下去，只是把东西留在那。有一个储油罐，显示这个地方曾经想建成一个加油站。
I've been there. It's remote. Dusty, makeshift houses, many without running water. The school, just a few houses scattered on the deep red earth. Carol's house was on the school grounds. Campus housing for both kids and teachers is pretty standard in Botswana actually. She got her keys, opened the door, all her stuff was there in boxes. She cried, and slept.
我去过那里。那里很偏远。尘土飞扬，临时的房子，许多没有自来水。学校就是散落在深红色土地上的几间房子。卡罗尔的家在学校操场上。在博茨瓦纳，为孩子和老师提供的校园住房实际上是相当标准的。她拿到钥匙，打开门，她所有的东西都在盒子里。她哭了，然后睡着了。
For days, she wouldn't leave the house. A few times, someone knocked, probably a fellow teacher or her boss. She ignored it. She had brought food for weeks-- rice, pasta, 10 pounds of dried chicken, and tons of hard cider. Finally, she showed up to work.
接连几天，她都不出屋子。敲了几次门，可能是别的老师或她的上司。她没理会。她带了几周的食物——米饭、意大利面、10磅干鸡肉，还有成吨的硬苹果酒。最后，她去上班了。
It was really odd. It was odd. Like I said, the people in that village-- even the teachers were like them. So I was wearing high-heeled shoes, I was carrying a handbag. Some were gossiping behind. Some were telling me straight, you know, my sister, this is a village. Eventually, you would leave your handbag at home, you would leave your high-heeled shoes.
真的太古怪了。真的很古怪。就像我说的，村里的人——连老师也和他们一样。所以我穿着高跟鞋，提着手提包。有些人背后议论。有些人直接跟我说，你知道，我的姐妹，这是个村庄。最终，你会把手提包留在家里，你会把高跟鞋丢掉的。
Then I said, for what? This is me. No one is going to change me. That's what I said. And you know, because of their attitude and what they said, I also had an attitude towards them.
然后我说，凭什么？这就是我。没人能改变我。我是这么说的。你知道，因为他们的态度和他们说的话，我也对他们产生了抵触情绪。
It's worth noting how this is basically the opposite of what the program is supposed to do. She's forced to go there. She didn't necessarily think anything bad about the people at first, but now she did. She didn't notice what she had in common with them. She noticed how they were different. Carol found herself in a corner that she hadn't really been in to start with.
值得注意的是，这基本上与该项目预期的目的背道而驰。她被迫去那里。她起初并不一定对那里的人有什么坏看法，但现在有了。她没有注意到她与他们的共同点。她只注意到了他们的不同。卡罗尔把自己困在了一个她最初并未陷入的角落里。
And I was angry with the Minister of Education. I was angry with everyone. They have abused me, they have ill-treated me.
我当时对教育部长很生气。我生所有人的气。他们滥用了我，他们虐待了我。
So I didn't even want to be a teacher anymore. At times, I would just go to class, I would look at these kids, I would just give them a book to read, and I would go back to my room.
所以我甚至不想当老师了。有时，我只是去教室，看着这些孩子，给他们一本书让他们读，然后我就回房间了。
Wow, so the students would sit there by themselves?
哇，所以学生们就自己坐在那儿？
The students would sit there by themselves. They would just read their books. I don't know whether they would be reading or making noise.
学生们自己坐在那儿。他们只是读书。我不知道他们是在读书还是在制造噪音。
Did you think to yourself, what happened to the girl who brought oranges to the classroom?
你有没有想过，那个带橙子去教室的女孩去哪儿了？
At that time, that thing didn't even cross my mind.
那时，那件事甚至没在我脑海里闪过。
Most of the teachers I talked to told me stories like this, but many were reluctant to go on the record. Carol, not so much. She was like, what the hell, this is what the government does to us, people should know about it.
大多数我采访的老师都告诉过我类似的故事，但许多人不愿录音。卡罗尔倒是无所谓。她说，管他呢，这就是政府对我们做的事，人们应该知道。
After a few weeks in the village, she had finished all the cider she had brought. So that night, she drove to the local bar and went in.
在村子里待了几周后，她喝完了所有带来的苹果酒。于是那天晚上，她开车去了当地的酒吧，走了进去。
I was just looking at these dirty people. To me, they were very dirty. And I wouldn't even look at them and see someone clean there.
我只是看着这些肮脏的人。对我来说，他们非常肮脏。我甚至不想看他们，在他们身上我看不到一点干净的样子。
Dirty in what way?
什么样的脏？
Dirty like they were not bathed, and they have a smell.
脏到就像他们没有洗澡一样，而且有一种味道。
So most of all, you remembered the smell.
所以最重要的是，你记住了那味道。
Yeah. It was horrible. I'm telling you. You know, the smell of armpits, and everything dirty, and the shoes? To me, I was somebody in a different class. They were not the type of people that I want to chat with, I would sit down with, I would laugh with. You know in a bar, when you get into a bar, there would be these guys that say, hey, baby, such things. And I would just look at them with this harsh face.
是的。太可怕了。我跟你说。你知道，腋下的味道，一切都是脏的，还有鞋子？对我来说，我是不同阶层的人。他们不是那种我想聊天、坐在一起、一起欢笑的人。你知道在酒吧里，当你走进一家酒吧，会有那些家伙说，嘿，宝贝，之类的东西。我就用那种严厉的脸看着他们。
Rolling your eyes.
翻着白眼。
Yeah, then they would say, uh oh, this one. And they will keep quiet. And I will get to the lady who's selling, and I will buy, and get outside, and get into my car and sit there and drink.
是的，然后他们会说，噢噢，这个女的。然后他们就闭嘴了。我就走到卖酒的女士那，买了酒，出来，回到我的车里，坐在那儿喝。
How many beers would you have a night?
你一晚上喝多少瓶啤酒？
Around six.
六瓶左右。
Six beers?
六瓶啤酒？
Yes.
是的。
The whole point of transferring teachers around the country is to expose them to people who are different from themselves. But whenever possible, Carol just tried to avoid that. Like the teachers, for example, they had a break room where they could eat lunch together and socialize.
全国范围调动老师的全部目的就是让他们接触不同的人。但只要可能，卡罗尔就尽量避免接触。比如，他们有个休息室，老师们可以在那里共进午餐和社交。
I only went there when there was a meeting-- only. I never sat with the teachers there, never. From the class, I go back to my house. I never sat with them.
我只有开会时才去那里——只有那个时候。我从来没有和老师们坐在那里，一次也没有。下课后，我就回我的房子。我从来没有和他们坐在一起。
Lunch break?
午休时间？
I never sat with them, never. I would rather sit in my car.
我从来没有和他们坐在一起，从来没有。我宁愿坐在我的车里。
After three months, she got a housemate, another teacher from a different part of the country. And one Saturday, he suggested going out to this nearby town that's just a little bit bigger. They brought their camping chairs, because on weekends, the bars can get so crowded that you don't find a place to sit. So they take the chairs, sit outside the bar, and Carol feels happy because the people there seem more like her kind of people.
三个月后，她有了一个室友，另一位来自该国不同地区的老师。一个周六，他建议去附近的一个城镇，稍微大一点的地方。他们带了露营椅，因为周末酒吧往往太挤，你找不到地方坐。所以他们拿着椅子，坐在酒吧外面，卡罗尔感到开心，因为那里的人看起来更像是她那一类的人。
[CAROL CHUCKLING]
[卡罗尔笑声]
No, we just had some drinks. It was a new environment for us.
没有，我们只是喝了点酒。那是我们接触的新环境。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
Why are you laughing?
你为什么笑？
I'm remembering exactly what happened.
我记起当时确切发生了什么。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
You know, you were just sitting there, chatting. And my housemate just went to the toilets. And there was this guy who approached me. He said hi. I said hi. And he said, my name is Thabo, can I please have your number? And then I was like, what do you want to do with my number? He said, no, I just wanted to chat with you. I feel like we can chat.
你知道，当时我们坐在那儿聊天。我的室友去洗手间了。有个家伙过来找我。他说你好。我说你好。他说，我叫塔博，可以要你的号码吗？我当时想，你要我的号码干什么？他说，不，我只是想和你聊天。我觉得我们可以聊得来。
Sometimes she gives out a fake number. But that guy, he got the real one.
有时她会给假号码。但那个家伙，他拿到了真号码。
I just felt like talking to him, being nice to him, and chatting with him. I just felt something from him the moment he came. Just, I don't know-- maybe that was the clinch of love. I don't know. Yes.
我只是想和他聊天，对他好，和他交谈。他走过来的那一刻我从他身上感觉到了一些东西。只是，我不知道——也许那就是爱情的碰撞。我不知道。是的。
What did he look like?
他长什么样？
Thabo.
塔博。
Yeah.
是的。
[CAROL CHUCKLING]
[卡罗尔笑声]
He was handsome.
他很帅。
What's so handsome about him?
他哪里帅？
No, I think beauty lies in the eyes. Maybe when you look at him, you will see him ugly. But when I look at him, handsome.
不，我认为美在眼中。也许当你看着他时，你会觉得他丑。但当我看着他时，他很帅。
He seemed like the guys she hung out with in the city, not like the people in the village. They talked a bit with the guys he was with.
他看起来和她在城里交往的那些人一样，不像村里的人。他们和他的伙伴们聊了聊。
We were talking, just like, yeah. And they said, oh, you guys, are you from here? We said, no. Then they said, where are you from? I kept quiet. Then my housemate said, we are from Lentsweletau. And they were like, what?
我们在谈话，就像，是的。他们说，噢，你们两个是本地人吗？我们说，不是。他们说，你们从哪儿来？我保持沉默。我的室友说，我们来自伦茨韦莱陶。他们说，什么？
Thabo, the guy who had asked for her number, said, that's my home village. It's where I grew up. My family lives there. This guy that Carol liked was from the town that she found so repulsive.
塔博，那个要她号码的家伙，说，那是我的家乡。我在那里长大。我的家人住在那儿。这个卡罗尔喜欢的家伙，正是来自她觉得如此厌恶的那个城镇。
And I know my housemate was laughing because he knew very well that I hate the place and everybody in that place. I always told him [SCOFFING] I don't like this place. I hate this place.
我知道我的室友在笑，因为他很清楚我讨厌那个地方和那里的每一个人。我总是告诉他[轻蔑地]我不喜欢这个地方。我讨厌这个地方。
What happened next is exactly what you think happened next. He visited her the next weekend, took her to parties, introduced her to friends, they got together. They traveled to South Africa, to the north of Botswana to see elephants. When they went out to dinner, he'd order the same thing she ordered. He lived a few hours away, so they only saw each other on weekends. But they'd talk on the phone.
接下来发生的事正如你所想的那样。他下周末去看她，带她去聚会，把她介绍给朋友，他们在一起了。他们去南非、去博茨瓦纳北部看大象。当他们去吃饭时，他会点和她一样的东西。他住在几个小时路程之外，所以他们只在周末见面。但他们会在电话里交谈。
You know, love chats, love chats.
你知道，情话，情话。
What do you mean, love chats?
什么是情话？
You know, he would ask me how I am, am I fine? If I wasn't, well, I will tell him, no, today, I have a headache, or what-- just those things.
你知道，他会问我好不好，我还好吗？如果我不舒服，好吧，我会告诉他，不，今天我头疼之类的——就是那些东西。
That's not a love chat, is it?
那不是情话，对吧？
It is. If you want to know how your partner is, that's the love chat.
是。如果你想知道你的伴侣好不好，那就是情话。
The transfer program was created to forge a nation. It's funny to think that this could be the real secret to how it might actually work-- people fall in love. For Carol, after she met Thabo--
调动计划是为了锻造一个国家。很有趣的是，这可能是它真正奏效的秘密——人们坠入爱河。对卡罗尔来说，在遇见塔博之后——
Everything changed. I started loving the place.
一切都变了。我开始爱上这个地方了。
How? How did that change?
怎么做到的？那种变化是怎么发生的？
Hmm?
嗯？
How did that change?
那种变化是怎么发生的？
You know, you have someone in the village, he's your boyfriend. He moves around, showing you things in the village. You tend to love the place.
你知道，你在村里有了某个人，他是你的男朋友。他带你四处走动，带你参观村里的事物。你倾向于爱上这个地方。
What did you discover about the place that before you hadn't seen?
你发现了这个地方之前你没看到的什么东西？
It's just a village. There isn't anything much.
它只是个村庄。没太多东西。
What do you love about it?
你爱它什么？
Those people, they are loving people.
那些人，他们是很有爱心的人。
You're smiling.
你在笑。
Yes. They are loving people. I love them. I love them.
是的。他们是很有爱心的人。我爱他们。我爱他们。
She became friends with the owner of the smelly bar. She cooked for the soccer team. She was invited to be a judge in a beauty contest, which is kind of a big deal in the village. She went to weddings and funerals. There was even a woman who gave her a piece of land.
她和那家难闻酒吧的老板成了朋友。她为足球队做饭。她受邀担任选美比赛的评委，这在村里算是件大事。她参加婚礼和葬礼。甚至还有个妇女给了她一块地。
I have built a house there.
我在那儿建了栋房子。
No way.
不会吧。
I'm telling you.
我跟你说。
No way.
不会吧。
Serious.
认真的。
[BOTH LAUGHING]
[两人笑声]
The former education minister Unity Dow, she says what Carol experienced is actually pretty common, and a big part of the program's success.
前教育部长尤妮蒂·多说，卡罗尔经历的其实很普遍，也是该项目成功的重要一部分。
What happens when you move people around? Maybe 80% will come back, 20% will stay, they get married.
当你四处调动人们时会发生什么？也许80%的人会回来，20%会留下，他们结婚了。
Oh, so it's a massive dating program.
哦，所以这是一个大型约会项目。
[UNITY CHUCKLING]
[尤妮蒂笑声]
I don't know if it's a-- I mean--
我不知道那是不是一个——我的意思是——
It's like a government-sponsored dating thing. People go someplace, they fall in love.
就像政府资助的约会活动。人们去某个地方，坠入爱河。
First of all, I'm going to say that you joke, but the truth is that it's just the nature of how humans move, and acclimatize, and call those their homes.
首先，我要说，虽然你在开玩笑，但事实是这就是人类移动、适应并称之为家的方式。
A few years after she had moved to the village, Carol finally felt at home. She had built that house, her relationship with Thabo was going great. Carol was taking oranges to class again. She did still bring her handbag and her heels to class every day. In fact, one of the women who teased her about it, a science teacher, she started bringing her handbag too.
搬到村子几年后，卡罗尔终于感到了家的归属感。她建了那栋房子，她与塔博的关系进展得非常顺利。卡罗尔又开始带橙子去教室了。她确实还是每天把手提包和高跟鞋带到教室。事实上，其中一个嘲笑她的女老师，一位科学老师，也开始带她的手提包了。
Carol was still a little bit of a snob about the locals. But overall, she was as happy here as she had been in the city.
卡罗尔对当地人仍然有一点势利。但总体来说，她在这里和在城里一样快乐。
But there is something I haven't told you about the transfer program. You don't just get transferred once. For teachers, it's every five years, sometimes a little less, sometimes a little more.
但关于调动计划，有些事我还没告诉你。你不只被调动一次。对于老师来说，每五年一次，有时少一点，有时多一点。
So one day--
所以有一天——
The school had called us. And it was a lady. She told us that one of you has to go.
学校叫我们去。是一位女士。她告诉我们，你们中有一个人得走。
There were five teachers teaching religious education, one too many.
当时有五位教宗教教育的老师，多了一个。
We asked her, what criteria are you going to use? So she basically said, whoever came first would be the one to go. And definitely, I knew it was me. So I think for about four or five months, I was waiting for the letter, knowing that any time I would go going.
我们问她，你打算用什么标准？所以她基本说，谁先来的谁就得走。我明确知道那个人是我。所以我认为大约有四五个月，我一直在等那封信，知道随时我都得走。
That must be so frustrating. I mean, now you're there, you know people intimately, and then you know that you have to start from the bottom.
那一定很令人沮丧。我的意思是，现在你已经在那儿了，你深入了解了人们，然后你知道你得从零开始。
Yes.
是的。
And you have to take all of this.
而且你得承受这一切。
It's really frustrating. Yeah, it is. It is. It is frustrating. It is frustrating a lot.
真的很令人沮丧。是的，确实如此。是的。这很令人沮丧。这非常令人沮丧。
On the other hand, if it weren't for the transfer program, she wouldn't have met Thabo.
另一方面，如果不是因为调动计划，她就不会遇到塔博。
Are you happy with him?
你和他在一起快乐吗？
Yeah, we are very much happy. And we are planning to get married.
是的，我们非常快乐。我们正在计划结婚。
(EXCITEDLY) Oh.
(兴奋地) 哦。
Probably some time-- April, May.
可能是在某个时候——四月，五月。
This was December last year. They had been together for 15 years at that point, survived three transfers. Thabo had never moved with her. As a soldier, he was also told by the government where to work.
这是去年十二月的事。那时他们在一起已经15年了，经历了三次调动。塔博从未随她调动。作为一名士兵，他也由政府决定在哪里工作。
But then, a couple of months after the interview, I was texting with Carol and she told me she had broke up with Thabo just before the wedding. She had found out that he was having an affair.
但后来，采访后的几个月，我在发短信给卡罗尔时，她告诉我，就在婚礼前她和塔博分手了。她发现他在搞婚外情。
Do you blame the transfer program for the end of your relationship with Thabo at all sometimes?
你有时会怪罪调动计划导致了你和塔博关系的终结吗？
Not really. A person's mentality it's not to be blamed on anyone or the government. No, I don't.
并没有。一个人的心态不能怪罪任何人或政府。不，我不会。
But if it wasn't for the transfer program, you would have been able to stay with him maybe and--
但如果不是调动计划，你也许能和他在一起，然后——
Maybe. I don't know. Yeah, maybe.
也许吧。我不知道。是的，也许吧。
Don't want to speculate.
不想做推测。
Yeah.
是的。
All the teachers I talked to found the transfer thing mostly annoying. Some of them found it so disruptive that, at some point, they considered quitting. Like, there was this one guy, after being transferred, he fell in love, much like Carol. He had a kid. But then he was transferred again, and again, and again.
我采访过的所有老师都觉得调动这件事大部分很烦人。有些人觉得它太具破坏性，以至于在某个时候，他们考虑辞职。比如，有个人在被调动后，和卡罗尔一样坠入爱河。他有个孩子。但他被一次、再一次、又一次地调动。
He worked in seven schools. He had four kids with four women. And he was single again when I talked to him. He blamed the transfers, and himself.
他在七所学校教过书。他和四个女人生了四个孩子。我采访他时他又单身了。他怪罪调动制度，也怪自己。
Recently, the government has made some changes. They now allow married people to move together. They've tried to reunite couples who have been split up. They also allow swaps. So if you find another teacher across the country who is willing to switch jobs, they'll usually agree.
最近，政府做出了一些改变。他们现在允许已婚人士一起调动。他们试图让被分开的夫妻团聚。他们也允许交换。所以如果你在全国范围内找到另一位愿意调换职位的老师，他们通常会同意。
So yes, they try to make things a little easier. But still, this policy is supposed to be intrusive. That's the idea. All the officials I talked to acknowledge the hardships it causes, and all of them stood by it. Yes, it was sometimes bad for individual people, but it was good for the people as a whole. In fact, they say it's a big reason why they are a whole.
所以是的，他们试图让事情变得简单一点。但这个政策本来就应该是侵入性的。这就是它的目的。我采访的所有官员都承认它带来的困难，并且所有人都坚持支持它。是的，它有时对个人不好，但对整个国民来说是好事。事实上，他们说这是他们成为一个整体的主要原因。
The effect of the transfers has never been systematically analyzed. There is no study. And Botswana had other things going for it that helped them unify. There was less of a colonial legacy to overcome. The British had kind of ignored the country, and ruled it from neighboring South Africa. And Botswana enacted those laws that prevented any one group from getting rich off the country's diamond wealth.
调动的影响从未被系统地分析过。没有研究。而且博茨瓦纳有其他帮助他们统一的因素。需要克服的殖民遗产较少。英国人基本上忽视了这个国家，并从邻国南非统治它。而且博茨瓦纳颁布了那些法律，防止任何单一群体利用该国的钻石财富暴富。
But the officials I talked to were convinced the transfers were essential. They helped make their country, drawn on a map 50 years ago, into a unified nation-- one that has never seen war, one that is the least corrupt country in Africa, and one of Africa's best-working democracies.
但我采访的官员们确信调动至关重要。他们帮助使这个50年前在地图上画出的国家，成为了一个统一的民族——一个从未见过战争的民族，非洲最廉价腐败的国家之一，也是非洲运作最好的民主国家之一。
And the economy? From the mid-'60s to the mid-'90s, Botswana had the fastest-growing economy in the world-- not the United States, not emerging China, Botswana.
那经济呢？从60年代中期到90年代中期，博茨瓦纳拥有世界上增长最快的经济——不是美国，不是新兴的中国，是博茨瓦纳。
It works miracles.
它创造了奇迹。
This is the president of Botswana, Mokgweetsi Masisi. I had the chance to speak to him a few weeks ago.
这是博茨瓦纳总统，莫克维齐·马西西。几周前我有幸采访了他。
In the same way as early on, when education system was still in its nascent stages, we had boarding schools. So you had people from this part of the country going over here and there. And people marry from everywhere. And it works for us.
就像早期一样，当教育系统还处于萌芽阶段时，我们有寄宿学校。所以有来自该国这个部分的人去往那边。人们与各处的人结婚。这对我们来说很有效。
I asked if some version of this might work elsewhere, like in the US and other countries that are so divided.
我问这种制度的某个版本是否可以在其他地方行得通，比如在美国和其他如此分裂的国家。
It could be a fix. But you know, I don't really want to comment too deeply about the issues of another nation state. You'd understand why. But I do have views.
它可能是一个解决方案。但你知道，我真的不想对另一个民族国家的事务评论太深。你会明白原因的。但我确实有观点。
[BASTIAN CHUCKLING]
[巴斯蒂安笑声]
They may just copy us-- copy from us.
他们可能只会复制我们——从我们这儿复制。
It's hard to imagine the US shipping teachers from New York City to red states, and vice versa. If you attempted this with teachers in Germany, where I live, you'd probably have riots on your hands. But we could try something to get different kinds of people talking to each other face to face.
很难想象美国会把纽约市的老师运往红州，反之亦然。如果你在我居住的德国尝试这个，你可能会引起骚乱。但我们可以尝试一些东西，让不同类型的人面对面交流。
Everybody I spoke with in Botswana told me the transfer program works, and everything I found in my reporting suggests it works. But I also got a glimpse of its limits.
我在博茨瓦纳采访的每个人都告诉我调动计划有效，我在报道中发现的一切也都表明它有效。但我也窥见了它的局限性。
One day, I gave a woman a ride, a young French teacher. We sat in the car waiting for the rain to pass, and she talked about her family, a family of teachers, a family shaped by transfers.
有一天，我载了一位妇女，一位年轻的法语老师。我们坐在车里等着雨过，她谈到了她的家庭，一个教师家庭，一个被调动所塑造的家庭。
My father was a teacher, and he was posted in another area. My mother was a teacher, and she was posted in another area. So he got on, did his naughty business, she got upset and left. But then I grew up knowing that the teacher was my father, but my father was someone else, was from another village somewhere in another tribe. So in essence, my mother raised me as a Motswana, and--
我父亲是老师，被派往另一个地区。我母亲是老师，被派往另一个地区。他继续工作，做了坏事，她很生气离开了。但后来我长大时知道那位老师是我父亲，但我父亲是别人，来自另一个部落的村庄。所以本质上，我母亲把我培养成了一个莫茨瓦纳人，而且——
A Motswana. In other words, a Botswanan.
一个莫茨瓦纳人。换句话说，一个博茨瓦纳人。
So I hate that question because--
所以我讨厌那个问题，因为——
Which question?
哪个问题？
"Omo gai."
“Omo gai。”
Yeah.
是的。
What does that mean?
那是什么意思？
What's your tribe? Or "hai g'gai," where's your home village?
你的部落是什么？或者“hai g'gai”，你的家乡在哪个村？
And is that a very common question?
那是一个非常普遍的问题吗？
It's a very common question. . Everyone will ask you that. Wherever you go, that's the first thing people will ask you.
这是一个非常普遍的问题。每个人都会问你那个。无论你去哪儿，那是人们会问你的第一件事。
"Omo gai."
“Omo gai。”
"Omo gai." It's like [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]. You get what I mean? So I don't like that. I'm just a Motswana. It doesn't matter where I come from. It doesn't matter where my village is-- de Motswana. And it's-- yeah.
“Omo gai。”就像[非英语发言]。你明白我的意思吗？所以我讨厌那个。我只是个莫茨瓦纳人。我来自哪里并不重要。我的村庄在哪里并不重要——我是个莫茨瓦纳人。而且——是的。
And that's not just an answer to shut the people up. It's what you really feel.
那不只是用来让人们闭嘴的回答。那是你内心真正的感受。
It's how I feel. I don't understand why we have to always identify with our tribes.
这是我的感受。我不明白为什么我们必须总是用我们的部落来标榜自己。
Do you realize that this is, in a nutshell, the Botswana story?
你意识到这就是博茨瓦纳故事的精髓吗？
Really? No I don't.
真的吗？不，我没有。
Don't you think?
你不觉得吗？
I guess now you're giving me that aha moment. Yeah, hey. [SPEAKING FRENCH]
我想现在你给了我那个顿悟的时刻。是的，嘿。[法语发言]
Then she started listing the Botswana tribes.
然后她开始列举博茨瓦纳的部落。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]. We are distributed all over the country. And we are all one. Thank you to the transfers, I guess.
[非英语发言]。我们遍布全国各地。我们都是一体的。多亏了调动制度，我想。
So yes, of course it has worked. Here's a woman who identifies first and foremost as Botswanan, who hasn't spoken her native language in years. But also, it hasn't worked, not all the way. I mean, they tried the most radical thing that I've found in my years of reporting on this. They did it for decades. They moved hundreds of thousands of people around. But the question is still being asked, what's your tribe?
所以是的，当然它奏效了。这是一个首先以自己是博茨瓦纳人为荣、多年没说母语的女人。但同时，它并没有完全奏效，没有彻底奏效。我是说，他们尝试了我多年报道生涯中发现的最激进的事情。他们做了几十年。他们调动了成千上万的人。但人们依然在问这个问题：你的部落是什么？
Bastian Berbner is a reporter for Die Zeit. If you speak German, he has a book about all this called, in German, 180 Degrees-- Stories Against Hate. He's looking for a publisher in English. Carol, by the way, after splitting up with Thabo, she met somebody new. They're planning to get married later this year.
巴斯蒂安·伯布纳是《时代周刊》的记者。如果你会德语，他有一本关于这一切的书，德语名为《180度——反仇恨的故事》。他正在寻找英语出版商。顺便提一下，卡罗尔在与塔博分手后，遇到了新的人。他们计划在今年晚些时候结婚。
Coming up, a bar where everybody knows your name. And that is exactly the problem. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，一个大家都知道你名字的酒吧。而这正是问题所在。节目稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台。
This is This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "Beer Summit," stories about people who disagree, trying to get along, aided by the magical healing power of beer. We've arrived at act two of our program-- Act Two, "Loggerheads."
这里是《这个美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《啤酒峰会》，讲的是人们在啤酒这种神奇疗愈力量的帮助下，如何试图和睦相处的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕——第二幕，“针锋相对”。
So we got a tip about this next story from a source I have to say we do not get many story ideas from. Ben Calhoun explains.
我们从一个来源得到了下一个故事的线索，我必须说，我们很少从那里得到故事想法。本·卡尔霍恩来解释。
Yeah, so a couple of years ago, I called this guy in Indiana.
是的，所以两年前，我给印第安纳州的这家伙打了电话。
Hello, Ben? Hi, Pete here in South Bend. How are you?
你好，本？嗨，我是南本德的皮特。你好吗？
Mayor Buttigieg, how are you?
布蒂吉格市长，你好吗？
Good. I apologize for running behind schedule today.
很好。我很抱歉今天耽误了时间。
No, I hear you have a whole city to run.
不，我听说你要管理整座城市。
[BOTH CHUCKLING]
[两人笑声]
This was way before Mayor Pete started running for president. These days, I don't imagine he does a ton of hour-long chats about the direction of the Democratic Party with reporters. Which, that's what we were doing.
这远在皮特市长开始竞选总统之前。这些天，我想他不会花大量时间与记者谈论民主党的方向。而那正是我们当时在做的。
And in the middle of that, he mentioned this thing that happened in South Bend.
在谈话中，他提到了南本德发生的事情。
I went to an event not long ago at the Clay Democratic Club, which is another sort of-- that's on the north side of town, and it resembles a dive bar. It's a place you can go for a concert and card game. And they had a big controversy because about half their board voted for Donald Trump, the Democratic Club.
不久前我参加了克莱民主俱乐部的一个活动，那也是某种——那是在镇的北边，它看起来像个廉价酒吧。那是你可以去听音乐会和打纸牌的地方。他们发生了一个大争议，因为他们的董事会大约一半人投票给了唐纳德·特朗普，那是民主党俱乐部。
Mayor Buttigieg was so matter-of-fact, it took me a second to register just how wild what he was saying was. That at one of the oldest, largest, most important Democratic clubs in his hometown, half the leadership had voted for Donald Trump in 2016.
布蒂吉格市长说得如此平淡，我花了几秒钟才反应过来他说的内容有多疯狂。在他家乡最古老、规模最大、最重要的民主党俱乐部之一，一半的领导层在2016年投票给了唐纳德·特朗普。
In other words, it was like, in the tiny world of this one bar, you had what the entire Democratic party's going through. In some key places like the Midwest, a bunch of Democrats deserted, and the Democrats lost, and the rest are left trying to figure it out. Are they mad at those people? Sure. Can they win those people back? What the heck is going to happen with those people?
换句话说，就像在这一家酒吧的微观世界里，你拥有了整个民主党正在经历的一切。在像中西部这样的关键地区，一大群民主党人背叛了，民主党输了，剩下的人在试图找出原因。他们对那些人感到愤怒吗？当然。他们能赢回那些人吗？到底会发生什么？
So a little while ago, I went to the Clay Democratic Club to see how this was all working out there.
所以不久前，我去克莱民主俱乐部看了看那里是怎么运作的。
[DOOR OPENING]
[开门声]
The Clay Democratic Club, it's sort of like an American Legion hall, crossed with a bingo hall, crossed with a neighborhood bar. Pool costs $1.25. Beers are $2.50. Because it's a private club, you can smoke, which is a well-exercised right. There's a stage in the back for drawings, bands, karaoke night.
克莱民主俱乐部，它有点像美国军团会馆，结合了宾果大厅，结合了社区酒吧。台球费1.25美元。啤酒2.50美元。因为它是私人俱乐部，你可以抽烟，这是一个被充分行使的权利。后面有个舞台，用于抽奖、乐队表演、卡拉OK之夜。
As a kid from Wisconsin, I would say it's pretty much everything a bar should be. Behind the stage, there's the club's logo, a red and blue donkey, with the name Clay Democratic Club over it. There's tables that the club moves around depending on what's happening. And at the bar, there are regulars who always seem to be in the same spots regardless of what's happening.
作为一个威斯康星州长大的孩子，我会说这基本上是酒吧该有的一切。在舞台后面，是俱乐部的标志，一头红蓝色的驴，上面写着“克莱民主俱乐部”的名字。桌子根据发生的事情搬动。在吧台，有些常客无论发生什么似乎总是坐在同一个位置。
Every time I stopped in, there was Marty on the right end of the bar, Denny in the middle, and then, down at the far left end of the bar, Liz, Liz McCombs.
我每次去的时候，马蒂总是坐在吧台右端，丹尼在中间，然后，在吧台左尽头是利兹，利兹·麦科姆斯。
The nights of elections, it will be packed down here-- bands and food. It's a huge event down here.
选举之夜，这里总是挤满了人——有乐队和食物。这里是个大活动点。
This whole thing started, Liz told me, on the eve of Indiana's last presidential primary, May 2, 2016. This was a Monday night. Donald Trump was in town. He was holding a big rally in South Bend, just a few miles south of the bar. They had it on all the bar's TVs.
利兹告诉我，这一切始于印第安纳州上一次总统初选的前夕，2016年5月2日。那是一个周一晚上。唐纳德·特朗普在城里。他要在南本德举行一场大型集会，就在离酒吧南面几英里远的地方。酒吧的所有电视上都在播。
We are just hours away from a critical vote in Indiana.
我们离印第安纳州的关键投票还有几个小时。
So everyone's watching the coverage of Trump on the bar's TVs, drinking.
所以每个人都在酒吧的电视上看特朗普的报道，一边喝酒。
There was a lot of offhand comments and things like that, because we were Democrats. So we definitely wanted to, for lack of better words, diss the Republicans and Trump.
有很多随口的评论之类的，因为我们是民主党人。所以我们肯定想，用词不当的话，嘲讽共和党人和特朗普。
And then it was over. The rally ended.
然后结束了。集会结束了。
When the rally was letting out, and they had it on the news-- so, the 11 o'clock news. And somebody said, oh my God, that's Russ. And it was.
当集会正在散场，新闻里播了——好吧，11点的新闻。有人说，噢天哪，那是拉斯。确实是。
Right there, on the TV, in the crowd streaming out of the Trump rally, was this guy that everybody in the bar recognized, a guy named Russ Thomas. Everyone recognized Russ because he was a longtime member of the Clay Democratic Club. But on top of that, Russ Thomas was the sitting President of the Clay Democratic Club.
就在电视上，在从特朗普集会涌出的人群中，那是每个人在酒吧都认识的家伙，一个叫拉斯·托马斯的男人。每个人都认识拉斯，因为他是克莱民主俱乐部的资深成员。更重要的是，拉斯·托马斯还是克莱民主俱乐部的在职主席。
And then everybody-- can I be blunt? They were-- oh, hell no, is what everybody was saying. Shock and awe. Shock and awe.
然后每个人——我可以直说吗？他们——哦，该死的不，每个人都说。震惊和敬畏。震惊和敬畏。
I called Russ to hear his version of all this. Russ, I'll say, is gruff but nice. He's a real connoisseur of short answers. "What is it that convinced you to support President Trump?" "I just like him." "But were there policies or certain issues?" "I just like him." He did have more than that to say about the rally, though-- mainly that he was completely and totally unapologetic.
我打电话给拉斯听听他的版本。拉斯，我得说，态度粗鲁但人不错。他是个回答简短的行家。“是什么让你决定支持特朗普总统？”“我就是喜欢他。”“但有什么政策或特定议题吗？”“我就是喜欢他。”不过他确实对集会说了些别的——主要是他完全没有任何道歉的意思。
If you had known that people at the club were watching TV that night, and they were seeing you on TV--
如果你知道俱乐部的人那天晚上在看电视，而且他们在电视上看到了你——
If I'd have know they were watching? I'd have had a banner that said, "Russ is here."
如果我知道他们在看？我会举着个横幅说，“拉斯在这儿。”
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
Might have waved at them-- how you doing, guys?
可能会向他们挥手——你们好吗，伙计们？
Russ says the rally was exciting. He went there with a buddy that night, another Democrat-turned-Trump supporter. It wasn't easy. Russ has problems with his legs, and by his account, could hardly walk. His friend couldn't use one foot because of diabetes. But they willed themselves through the walk to South Bend's convention center. And then they stood and waited until Donald Trump made his entrance-- to the Rolling Stones' "Start Me Up."
拉斯说集会令人兴奋。他那天晚上和哥们儿一起去了，另一个变节成特朗普支持者的民主党人。这不容易。拉斯的腿有毛病，据他自己说，几乎走不动。他的朋友因为糖尿病一只脚不能用。但他们意志坚强地走到了南本德的会议中心。然后他们站在那儿等着，直到唐纳德·特朗普进场——伴随着滚石乐队的《Start Me Up》。
[MUSIC - THE ROLLING STONES, "START ME UP"]
[音乐 - 滚石乐队，《Start Me Up》]
So if I'm facing the president, where were you in the room?
所以如果我面对总统，你当时在房间的哪儿？
He's right over there.
他在那儿。
Russ points, indicating he was in the back, back towards the back right corner of the room.
拉斯指着，表示他在后面，房间右后方角落。
Yeah, I'm back on this back wall back there, standing.
是的，我就在那后面靠着墙站着。
But we had such incredible crowds. Look at this room as an example-- right into the corners, people. Hello, corner.
但我们有如此令人难以置信的人群。看这个房间为例——直接挤到了角落，伙计们。你好，角落。
How far away were you from him?
离他有多远？
I was almost to the other wall.
我快到另一面墙了。
So pretty far in the back.
所以离后面相当远。
It was awesome, everybody clapping and yelling. Awesome.
太棒了，每个人都在鼓掌和叫喊。太棒了。
Indiana's primary comes pretty late in the process. But that night, Trump was on the verge of effectively locking up the Republican nomination. And he told Russ and his buddy in the crowd there that their votes the next day could put him over the top.
印第安纳州的初选在整个进程中相当靠后。但那天晚上，特朗普处于有效锁定共和党提名的边缘。他告诉拉斯和人群中的伙计，他们第二天投票就能帮他跨过门槛。
Now Indiana is becoming very important. It's usually, by this time, it's over, and you know, it doesn't matter. But this time, you folks belong where you belong. It's called Importantville, right?
现在印第安纳州变得非常重要。通常，到这个时候，已经结束了，你知道，没意义了。但这次，你们这些民众属于你们所属的地方。它叫重要镇，对吧？
[CROWD CHEERING]
[人群欢呼]
Importantville, I love it.
重要镇，我爱死这个名字了。
Of course, that night in Importantville, not everyone was feeling so great about stuff, specifically the patrons of one Democratic bar who'd been watching TV.
当然，那天晚上在重要镇，并不是每个人都对此感觉很好，特别是正在看电视的民主党酒吧的常客们。
Anger, embarrassment, rage. There was people that were raging.
愤怒，尴尬，狂怒。有人在发狂。
Again, Liz McCombs, longtime Clay Democratic Club member.
又是利兹·麦科姆斯，克莱民主俱乐部的老会员。
It was every emotion. Because you felt like the rug had been ripped out underneath your feet. It was like The Wizard of Oz. You're really a Republican running a Democratic Club. Never mind what's behind that curtain. It was exactly like The Wizard of Oz.
这是一种混合情绪。因为你感觉像脚下的地毯被扯掉了。就像《绿野仙踪》。你其实是个经营民主党俱乐部的共和党人。别管幕后是什么。简直就像《绿野仙踪》。
It probably seems like Russ could not have been more busted, but he was. The head of the St. Joseph County Democratic Party-- that's the county where South Bend is-- the head of the entire Democratic Party at that time was a guy named Jason Critchlow. Jason was outside the Trump rally that night, just checking out the Trump supporters. And then what happened, he looks across the street, he told me. Who do I see? It's Russ fucking Thomas.
拉斯看起来好像不可能更被抓现行了，但他确实是。圣约瑟夫县民主党主席——就是南本德所在的县——当时的整个民主党主席是一个叫杰森·克里奇洛的家伙。杰森那天晚上在特朗普集会外面，看看支持者。接着发生了什么，他告诉我说，他朝街对面看。我看到了谁？是那个该死的拉斯·托马斯。
I think he was wearing a hat. It was one of those things where it wasn't an accident and he was just walking along the sidewalk. It was obvious this dude was going into the rally and was a Trump supporter, you know?
我想他戴着帽子。那不是什么意外，他只是沿人行道走。显而易见这家伙要去参加集会，是个特朗普支持者，你知道吗？
Jason was like, I'm the county party chair, this is kind of a weird thing for me to get mixed up in, but also kind of too big of a deal to just let go.
杰森当时想，我是县党部主席，这对我来说有点奇怪，但同时也太大了，不能就这么算了。
You know, how much of a fight do I want to pick over something? And this is their club, it's their rules.
你知道，我为了某事要挑起多大的争斗？这是他们的俱乐部，这是他们的规矩。
Not knowing what to do, Jason started calling and texting a small group of people who he knows go to the club. Eventually, he gets to Dan Hardman, former president of the Clay Democratic Club.
不知道该怎么办，杰森开始给一些他认识的去俱乐部的人打电话发短信。最终，他联系上了丹·哈德曼，克莱民主俱乐部的前主席。
He asked me, what's going on? I told him-- I said, Jason, I don't know. I'm not an officer at the club anymore.
他问我，发生了什么？我告诉他——我说，杰森，我不知道。我不再是俱乐部的官员了。
Dan Hardman is like everything about the Clay Democratic Club turned into a person. His life seems to rhyme with everything about the place. Dan was born in South Bend in 1946, same year as the club. In the beginning, the founders didn't have enough money for a building. They just poured a basement and put a roof on it.
丹·哈德曼就像克莱民主俱乐部化身为人。他的生活似乎与这个地方的一切押韵。丹1946年出生在南本德，和俱乐部同龄。起初，创始人们没有足够的钱盖楼。他们只是浇筑了一个地下室，盖了个屋顶。
Some of Dan's early memories are of being a little kid, running around on the low-slung roof of that basement building while the adults were downstairs in the club. Dan was a member for years, eventually became vice president. Dan was president for seven years before Russ came in.
丹早期的一些记忆是还是小孩子的时候，在地下室建筑低矮的屋顶上跑来跑去，而大人们在楼下的俱乐部里。丹做了多年会员，最终成为了副主席。丹做了七年主席，然后拉斯才接任。
For anything bad to happen down here, it kind of affects me emotionally because I've got such strong feelings for the membership and the club. My desire to have this club succeed is just humongous. I mean, anything goes wrong with this club, I feel it's part of me.
这里发生任何坏事，都会从情感上影响我，因为我对会员和俱乐部有如此强烈的感情。我希望这个俱乐部成功的欲望太巨大了。我的意思是，这个俱乐部出任何问题，我都觉得这是我的一部分。
And so do most of my officers. They feel that way. And that's the way the officers of the club should feel. This club is part of them. And that don't mean that your life revolves around it, but close to it.
我的大多数官员也一样。他们有这种感觉。这就是俱乐部官员应该有的感觉。这个俱乐部是他们的一部分。这并不意味着你的生活绕着它转，但差不多了。
Everyone at the club seems to love Dan, which is easy. He's not a big guy, but he seems big because he's so outgoing. He's a grandfather of 16, retired Teamster, drove a truck for years, Army veteran. He's got this completely bald head and a long gray goatee.
每个人似乎都爱丹，这很容易。他个子不大，但他看起来很大，因为他太外向了。他是16个孩子的祖父，退休的卡车司机，开了多年卡车，陆军老兵。他完全秃顶，留着长长的灰色山羊胡。
When Dan got the call from Jason about Russ, it was the first he'd heard of any of this. Dan was reeling.
丹接到杰森关于拉斯的电话时，这是他第一次听说这一切。丹当时晕头转向。
What do you feel? I mean, the president of your club, your Democratic Club, is seen at a rally for a Republican candidate for president. What are you doing, dude? I mean, you're putting a black mark on our party, on our club.
你感觉如何？我的意思是，你的俱乐部主席，你的民主党俱乐部，被发现在共和党总统候选人的集会上。伙计，你在干什么？我的意思是，你在给我们的政党、我们的俱乐部抹黑。
Dan, who'd known Russ for years, ended up being the one to have to call him to see what this was about.
认识拉斯多年的丹，最终不得不打电话问他这是怎么回事。
I confronted him about it-- why did you do that, Russ? Because I believe in the man. I support Trump. He says, I'm not a Republican but I support Trump. I said, you're the president of the Democratic Club, and you're doing that to your Democratic Party? It doesn't look very good, Russ. I mean, you could have sat at home and watched it on TV or in any other venue.
我当面质问他——拉斯，你为什么要那么做？因为我相信那个人。我支持特朗普。他说，我不是共和党人但我支持特朗普。我说，你是民主党俱乐部的主席，你是在那样对待你的民主党吗？这看起来不太好，拉斯。我的意思是，你可以坐在家里在电视上或任何其他地方看。
And he said, that's my right to do that. And I said, OK, I appreciate that. You have your rights. Do whatever you want to do. I didn't raise hell or anything like that, because that doesn't get you anywhere.
他说，我有权利那么做。我说，好的，我尊重这一点。你有你的权利。做你想做的事。我没有大吵大闹什么的，因为那解决不了问题。
At the club meeting that soon followed, Dan asked everyone to, quote, "not crucify their friend for his beliefs."
在随后的俱乐部会议上，丹要求每个人，引用：“不要因为他的信仰而钉死他们的朋友。”
Right away, they wanted to kick him out of the club, right away. They wanted to tar and feather the poor guy and run him off.
马上，他们就想把他赶出俱乐部，马上。他们想把这家伙浸在焦油里盖上羽毛，赶走他。
Well, it wasn't me, but it was other people stating, he's gone, he's done, we're done.
好吧，不是我，但其他人说，他完了，他被踢了，我们完了。
Again, Liz McCombs. Liz says she was friends with Russ, still is friends with Russ. But she says most people-- at least, the ones that spoke up at this meeting-- drew a hard line about what he did.
还是利兹·麦科姆斯。利兹说她和拉斯是朋友，现在依然是朋友。但她说大多数人——至少在会上发言的那些人——对他所做的事画了一条硬线。
This Democratic Club, we are old yellow dogs. And what that means is I'd rather vote for an old yellow dog than a Republican. So they just labeled him as a turncoat. And that was it, it was impossible.
这个民主党俱乐部，我们是老黄狗。这意味着我宁愿投票给一只老黄狗也不投给共和党人。所以他们就给他贴上了变节者的标签。就这样，这不可能。
It was like there was just no way that he could even function as president anymore.
就好像他根本不可能再担任主席一样。
No, you lied to everybody. No. There's-- no. He just-- he did not understand what his position meant and how much it meant.
不，你对所有人撒谎了。不。这——不。他就是——他没理解他的位置意味着什么，以及它有多重要。
Russ resigned as president. A couple of people told me he wasn't doing that good of a job anyway. Russ denies that. The only thing Russ would say is that it was, quote, "personal." No matter how many times I asked, that's what he said. What I do know, Russ submitted a very succinct letter of resignation shortly after the incident at the rally. No reasons, just that he was stepping down as president of the Clay Democratic Club. Dan Hardman came back for another term, like FDR.
拉斯辞去了主席职务。有几个人告诉我他本来也干得不好。拉斯否认这一点。拉斯唯一会说的就是这是，引用：“个人的”。不管我问多少次，他都这么说。我知道的是，拉斯在集会事件后不久提交了一封非常简短的辞职信。没有原因，只是说他要辞去克莱民主俱乐部主席职务。丹·哈德曼又做了一任主席，就像罗斯福一样。
But what makes all of this complicated is that Russ quit as president, but he kept coming into the club because it's a great bar full of people he knows, and because Russ still considers himself a Democrat-- previously, now, in the future. He says he just likes Trump.
但让这一切复杂化的是，拉斯辞去了主席，但他继续来到俱乐部，因为这是一个满是他认识的人的伟大酒吧，而且因为拉斯依然认为自己是民主党人——过去、现在、未来。他说他只是喜欢特朗普。
He's outspoken, he's doing a good job. I got a lot of faith in him. I feel the same way about him that I did with Reagan.
他直言不讳，他工作做得不错。我对他很有信心。我对他有和对里根一样的感觉。
Oh, is that right? So did you-- you voted for Reagan?
哦，是吗？所以你投票给了里根？
Yep.
是的。
So do you feel like there's a couple times in your life when-- for the most part you've been a Democrat, but there's been a few times in your life that you said, I'm voting for the Republican in this case.
所以你觉得你一生中有几次——大部分时间你是民主党人，但有几次你投票给共和党人。
I split my ticket every year, every vote. I still vote some Democrat. I voted Obama's first year.
我每年都会分裂投票，每一次。我依然投一些民主党人的票。我投了奥巴马第一年。
At this point, it seems like it became clear that the Russ Thomas situation wasn't just going to be about Russ.
在这一点上，情况似乎变得清楚，拉斯·托马斯的情况不仅仅是关于拉斯。
When Russ did this, it split everybody apart, because you're either a Democrat or you're not.
当拉斯这么做时，这分裂了所有人，因为你要么是民主党人，要么不是。
Liz McCombs says things changed at the club in the months that followed. When Dan Hardman came back as president, he told Russ if he was going to keep coming in, he had to be tactful about his support for Trump. But Dan also made sure Russ knew that he was still welcome. And so Russ continued to do some of the things he'd always done, like run karaoke at the club on Friday nights, which is how karaoke night turned into a time for people at the club to choose sides.
利兹·麦科姆斯说俱乐部在接下来的几个月里变了。丹·哈德曼回来当主席时，他告诉拉斯如果他要继续来，就必须对自己支持特朗普这件事保持机智。但丹也确保拉斯知道他依然受欢迎。所以拉斯继续做他一直做的一些事情，比如周五晚上在俱乐部主持卡拉OK，这就是卡拉OK之夜变成了俱乐部成员选边站的时候。
So you had people gunning for Russ-- that's true. And then you had Russ supporters, which I get. It's freedom of speech. You're allowed that, and you're allowed to do whatever you want, and that's part of the Constitution, and I'm thankful every day we have that. That's fine in everybody's regular life.
所以你有人想干掉拉斯——那是真的。然后你有拉斯的支持者，我懂。这是言论自由。你被允许那样做，你被允许做任何你想做的事，那是宪法的一部分，我很感激每天我们都有那个。在每个人的常规生活中那很好。
But what did those people do when they would come down? How often would it happen that people would stir up trouble about Trump after that?
但当人们过来时，他们会做什么？在那之后，人们因为特朗普惹麻烦发生的频率有多高？
It seemed like every weekend, because Russ was doing the karaoke. And it seemed like there was a fight every Friday night. Every time he played, somebody would just start yelling and being out of control. Because he was up on stage doing the karaoke. So he kind of made himself the target.
似乎每个周末都这样，因为拉斯在搞卡拉OK。似乎每个周五晚上都有架打。每次他播放，就会有人开始尖叫并失去控制。因为他站在台上搞卡拉OK。所以他把自己变成了目标。
Wait, so would it go both ways? Would it be like he would run the karaoke night, and somebody would yell something at him? They would heckle him about what had happened.
等等，是双向的吗？就像他会主持卡拉OK，然后有人会对他大喊大叫？他们会因为发生的事情嘲讽他。
Absolutely. And then there were people that felt sorry for him. Because--
当然。然后有些人觉得他可怜。因为——
And they would defend him?
他们会保护他？
Yes. Because he's an aging man, and they're uneducated, and they didn't understand what he did.
是的。因为他是个老头，他们没教养，他们不理解他所做的。
Russ estimates that maybe 10% of the club's members like President Trump, and others said the same thing. But most of the Trump supporters keep it quiet-- most, though definitely not all.
拉斯估计也许10%的俱乐部成员喜欢特朗普总统，其他人也这么说。但大多数特朗普支持者保持安静——大多数，虽然肯定不是全部。
Another contingent increasingly came into the club spoiling for a fight, looking to mix it up. Dan Hardman, and Liz McCombs, and a number of others say the loudest was a guy named Mike Powell.
另一群人越来越多地来到俱乐部寻找打架机会，想要加入战斗。丹·哈德曼、利兹·麦科姆斯和其他一些人说最大声的是个叫迈克·鲍威尔的家伙。
He would pound his fist on the bar-- Trump, Trump, Trump, Trump, Trump.
他会用拳头砸吧台——特朗普，特朗普，特朗普，特朗普，特朗普。
Like Russ, Mike's a lifelong Democrat, member of the club for years, who decided to support Trump. Dan Hardman told me Mike would come into his office at the club and try to convince Dan to defect like he had. Again, here's Liz.
像拉斯一样，迈克是终身民主党人，在俱乐部待了多年，决定支持特朗普。丹·哈德曼告诉我迈克会来到他在俱乐部的办公室，试图说服丹也叛变。还是利兹。
Why would you come to a Democratic Club to be a Trumper?
为什么你要来民主党俱乐部当特朗普分子？
Like, when you say that he would pound his fists on the bar and say, "Trump, Trump, Trump," that is what he would say?
就像，当你提到他会用拳头砸吧台说，“特朗普，特朗普，特朗普”时，那就是他会说的？
Trump, Trump, Trump-- literally. And that's kind of how the Trumpers are. That's exactly how Mike Powell behaves.
特朗普，特朗普，特朗普——字面上。这就是特朗普分子的情况。这就是迈克·鲍威尔的行为方式。
Surprisingly-- and unsurprisingly-- Mike Powell sees this whole situation differently. Mike's account-- he has not gone looking for fights about Trump. In fact, he feels, if anything, it's been the other way around.
令人惊讶的是——也不足为奇——迈克·鲍威尔以不同方式看待这一切。迈克的陈述——他没有去寻找关于特朗普的斗争。事实上，他觉得，如果有的话，恰恰相反。
I mean, everybody knows how I feel. And if somebody sits down next to me and starts cutting down Trump, I'll say, you're talking to the wrong guy-- wrong guy. Talk over there.
我的意思是，每个人都知道我的感受。如果有人坐在我旁边开始诋毁特朗普，我会说，你找错人了——错人了。去那边说。
[CHUCKLING]
[笑声]
And sometimes they get mad, and oh well.
有时他们会生气，噢好吧。
There was a blow-up over the situation at a board meeting at the club when they discussed Russ's support for Trump and the impact it was having. According to a few accounts I've heard, someone-- a longtime Democrat-- stood up and he said some version of, half the board didn't even vote Democratic. Club president Dan Hardman shot back saying that wasn't true. Though I guess that comment about half the board is what produced the story that spread through Democratic circles, and eventually made its way to Mayor Buttigieg.
关于拉斯支持特朗普及其产生的影响，在俱乐部的一次董事会会议上发生了激烈争吵。根据我听到的几个说法，有人——一个资深民主党人——站起来说了一句，有一半董事会成员甚至没投民主党。俱乐部主席丹·哈德曼反驳说那不是真的。虽然我猜关于半个董事会的那句话造成了传遍民主党圈子并最终传到布蒂吉格市长的故事。
At this meeting, Mike Powell told me he got called out as a Trump supporter, to which he yelled back, it's none of your business how I voted. Mike told me a staunch Democrat started shouting at Mike's wife, who is the club's financial secretary. He was pointing a finger in her face. Mike told me he went up to the guy after the meeting and told him if he pointed a finger in his wife's face again he'd break it off and shove it up his ass.
在这个会议上，迈克·鲍威尔告诉我他作为特朗普支持者被点名，他回喊道，我怎么投票跟你没关系。迈克告诉我，一个死硬民主党人开始对迈克的妻子大喊大叫，她当时是俱乐部的财务秘书。他指着她的脸。迈克告诉我会议后他走到那个家伙面前，告诉他如果他再指着他妻子的脸，他就把那根手指折断塞进他的屁股里。
Dan Hardman says he's done what he could to limit the damage as stories like this have circulated. He wrote in the newsletter telling people not to believe everything they heard, making it clear that it was a Democratic Club for Democrats.
丹·哈德曼说，随着这些故事流传，他竭尽所能限制损害。他在通讯中写道，告诉人们不要相信听到的一切，明确表示这是一个民主党人经营的民主党俱乐部。
Dan told me, leading up to all this, membership at the club had already been declining. But all this strife, it made it worse.
丹告诉我，在这一切之前，俱乐部的会员数量已经在下降。但这所有的争斗，让情况更糟了。
We went down from nearly 1,000 members, to right now, we're looking at maybe 300. And that membership is hard to keep together, because we can't get people to come down, because they think that we turned our backs on them.
我们从近1000名会员下降到现在的300人左右。那个会员资格很难维持，因为我们没法让人们过来，因为他们认为我们背弃了他们。
He means Democrats didn't think the club was really for Democrats anymore.
他的意思是民主党人认为俱乐部不再真正属于民主党人。
And there are some that I haven't seen in, oh, heck, three years.
有些我已经，噢该死的，三年没见了。
That must have been difficult to go through with a club that you'd been running, and that you'd built over the course of years.
经历了你经营了这么多年、一手建立的俱乐部变成这样，一定很难过。
Yeah. Oh yeah, it was heartbreaking. It was really heartbreaking. I don't know. I don't know why they don't come back.
是的。噢是的，这令人心碎。真的令人心碎。我不知道。我不知道他们为什么不回来。
Mike and Russ, the more they've come under attack from their Democratic friends, the more they've sought the company of those who agree with them. Russ told me, these days, he's relying almost entirely on Fox News. Both guys read a lot of conservative stuff that they get from other Trump supporters on the internet. Democrats want open borders. President Obama wanted one world government. Mike said he doesn't want Muslims in our government. That scares the tar out of me, he said.
迈克和拉斯，受到民主党朋友攻击得越多，他们就越寻求那些同意他们观点的人的陪伴。拉斯告诉我，这些日子，他基本上完全依赖福克斯新闻。两人都读了很多从网上其他特朗普支持者那里得到的保守派材料。民主党想要开放边境。奥巴马总统想要世界政府。迈克说他不想要穆斯林进入我们的政府。那让我恐惧万分，他说。
I asked both of them what the Democrats might do to win them back, if that was even possible. Russ said, maybe for 2024, but I'm sticking with Trump. Mike told me he likes some of what he heard from Tulsi Gabbard and Amy Klobuchar, but really, it was pretty unlikely.
我问他们俩民主党可以做什么来赢回他们，如果那还有可能的话。拉斯说，2024年也许，但我依然支持特朗普。迈克告诉我他喜欢他在塔西·加巴德和艾米·克洛布查尔那里听到的一些内容，但实际上，这非常不可能。
What do you think the Democrats don't understand about somebody like you or somebody like Russ, who identified for a long time as a Democrat, and then they left for Trump?
你认为民主党人对于像你或像拉斯这样长期作为民主党人、然后离开投奔特朗普的人，有什么不理解的？
I don't think they care. That's the deal. They have an agenda. And they don't care what we think anymore. I mean, everything is about illegals, and the poor, and everything else. They don't care about us anymore. They just don't. It's just like we're irrelevant, you know? You don't give a shit about us.
我不认为他们关心。就是这样。他们有议程。他们不再关心我们怎么想了。我的意思是，一切都是关于非法移民，和穷人，以及其他的一切。他们不再关心我们了。就是这样。就像我们无关紧要，你知道吗？你根本不在乎我们。
So if there was a Democratic politician, though, and you felt like that is somebody who cares about a guy like me--
所以如果有一个民主党政客，而且你觉得那个人是在关心像我这样的人——
That's a big deal.
那是一件大事。
That's the kind of thing that could get you back.
那就是能让你回来的那种事。
That's huge, yes. You know, it ain't just what Trump does, but it's about feeling like you matter. You know what I mean? If you think somebody don't give a crap about you, what does it matter? You're going to go towards somebody that cares, somebody that thinks you matter. That's the bottom line. What about us?
那太巨大了，是的。你知道，不仅仅是特朗普做什么，而是感觉你很重要。你知道我的意思吗？如果你认为有人根本不在乎你，那有什么关系？你会转向关心你、认为你重要的人。这就是底线。我们呢？
There's a certain schizophrenia to Russ and Mike's politics these days. Even though they support President Trump, their biggest concerns still do seem to be traditionally Democratic causes. Russ says he's concerned about health care. And if somebody could present a plan to get everybody covered, he'd be for that. Mike also worries about health care, and the cost of prescription drugs, and about the quality of public education in America.
拉斯和迈克的政治这些日子有一种精神分裂症。尽管他们支持特朗普总统，他们最大的担忧似乎依然是传统的民主党议题。拉斯说他关心医保。如果有人能提出一个覆盖所有人的计划，他会支持。迈克也担心医保、处方药成本以及美国公立教育的质量。
They both told me the story of the Democratic Party they were loyal to, that they still love, was the story of a party that was for the little guy and against the big guy. I told them, I think many of the Democrats running now still talk about the party that way. And they're making proposals to do things that both men say they want. But whatever the story the Democrats are telling, Russ and Mike do not see themselves in it.
他们俩都告诉我，他们忠诚并依然热爱的民主党故事，是一个为小人物、反对大人物的政党。我告诉他们，我认为现在竞选的许多民主党人依然用那种方式谈论政党。他们正在提议做两男人都说他们想要的事情。但不管民主党人讲什么故事，拉斯和迈克都没在里面看到自己。
The one part of the Democrats' message that seems to be getting through to Russ and Mike is just how badly they all want to get rid of Trump, which just makes them want to defend him. One Democrat who's had to come up with a strategy for how to deal with the Russes and Mikes of the world is club President Dan Hardman. And his strategy could pretty much be boiled down to, let's just all try to chill out some, go easy on each other, maybe have a beer.
民主党人似乎传达给拉斯和迈克的唯一消息就是他们想除掉特朗普的意愿有多么强烈，这只会让他们想要保卫他。有一位民主党人必须想出如何应对世界上的拉斯和迈克们的战略，那就是俱乐部主席丹·哈德曼。他的战略基本上可以总结为：让我们都试着冷静下来，对彼此放轻松，也许喝杯啤酒。
Russ isn't so interested in hearing from any Democratic politicians right now. But he also made a point of telling me about this thing that Dan did for him after all this went down. Russ lost his wife, Carol, earlier this year. They'd been together since high school. After she died, Russ got really depressed. In the middle of that, Dan organized a dinner for him, and he held it at the Democratic Club. Russ says that-- that meant so much to him.
拉斯现在没兴趣听任何民主党政客说的话。但他确实特意向我提起这件事，那是丹在这一切发生后为他做的。拉斯今年早些时候失去了他的妻子卡罗尔。他们从高中就在一起。她去世后，拉斯变得非常抑郁。在那种情况下，丹为他组织了一场晚餐，并在民主党俱乐部举行。拉斯说——那对他意义重大。
And so there is one Democrat I know for a fact Russ respects, that he listens to, and that he likes. It's a guy who keeps letting him know he's welcome to sit with him at the bar, regardless of who's in the White House.
所以有一个民主党人我知道拉斯确实尊重、倾听并喜欢他。那是即使白宫里是谁，也一直让他知道他欢迎坐在他身边的人。
Ben Calhoun is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - GEORGE STRAIT, "COLD BEER CONVERSATION"]
[音乐 - 乔治·斯特雷特，《冷啤酒谈话》]
(SINGING) Cold beer conversations, just a couple old boys, a little time well wasted. Trying to figure out life, trying to figure out girls, trying to find our place in this crazy old world.
(歌唱) 冷啤酒谈话，只是几个老伙计，一点虚度的时光。试图弄清楚生活，试图弄清楚女孩，试图在我们这个疯狂的老世界里找到我们的位置。
Well, the program was produced today by Zoe Chace with help from Elna Baker. The people who put together today's show includes Emanuele Berry, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Damian Grave, Jessica Lussenhop, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katharine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Tracy Roland, Robyn Semien, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Managing editor is Diane Wheeler, executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Sarah Dryden-Peterson, Moses Ochonu, the Pew Research Center, NDR in Hamburg, Betty Olivier, and Denny Grounds.
好吧，节目今天由佐伊·蔡斯制作，埃尔娜·贝克的帮助。制作今天节目的包括埃马努埃莱·贝里、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格雷夫、杰西卡·卢森霍普、米基·米克、莉娜·米西齐斯、斯托·纳尔逊、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、本·费伦、纳迪亚·雷曼、特雷西·罗兰、罗宾·塞米恩、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和南希·厄普代克。管理编辑是黛安·惠勒，执行编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢莎拉·德莱顿-彼得森、摩西·奥乔努、皮尤研究中心、汉堡NDR、贝蒂·奥利维尔和丹尼·格兰兹。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 680 episodes. And there's videos and tons of other stuff there too. Or get our app, which has all that stuff and also lets you download as many episodes as you want. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以流媒体收听我们超过680集的档案。那里还有视频和其他成吨的东西。或者获取我们的应用程序，它有所有东西，也让你能下载你想要的集数。还是那句话，ThisAmericanLife.org。《这个美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换中心发送给公共广播电台。
Thanks as always to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he just signed up with the Hair Club for Men. He seems to be taking it very seriously. But to be honest, I am not sure he understands it.
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他刚刚注册了男士头发俱乐部。他看起来对待它非常认真。但说实话，我不确定他理解它。
My desire to have this club succeed is just humongous. I mean, anything goes wrong with this club, I feel it's a part of me.
我希望这个俱乐部成功的欲望太巨大了。我的意思是，这个俱乐部出任何问题，我都觉得这是我的一部分。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于这个美国生活的故事。
[MUSIC - GEORGE STRAIT, "COLD BEER CONVERSATION"]
[音乐 - 乔治·斯特雷特，《冷啤酒谈话》]
(SINGING) A little truth, a little frustration. It's just us, man. Go on and say it. Cold beer conversation.
(歌唱) 一点真相，一点沮丧。伙计，就是我们，说出来吧。冷啤酒谈话。